OFFICIAL.
THANK YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE HAVE TWO HUGE MASSIVE
BREAKING NEWS STORIES ON THE
DEEP STATE.
ONE HOW INCONTROVERT
TILLABLE EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE WAS PURPOSEFULLY
HELD FROM THE FISA COURT.
THE EVIDENCE IS IN.
THAT BLOCKBUSTER NEWS AND
PETER STRZOK'S HIDDEN
TESTIMONY TONIGHT.
WE HAVE ALL THE DETAILS.
WE BEGIN WITH OTHER NEWS.
OF THE SYSTEM WAS RIGGED NOW
COUNTLESS STUDENTS WILL
APPLY TO GEORGETOWN, USC,
STANFORD, YALE, ALL THESE
OTHER TOP UNIVERSITIES WERE
LIKELY CHEATED OUT OF THEIR
SPOT BECAUSE IN THIS CASE IT
IS A ZERO SUM GAME ALL
BECAUSE DOZENS, PERHAPS NOW
AS MANY AS 800 I'M READING
WEALTHY FAMILIES SELFISHLY
MADE MASSIVE PAYMENTS TO
THIS MAN RIGHT HERE NAMED
RICK SINGER IN ORDER TO FIX
A SAT SCORE BRIBE OFFICIAL
COLLEGE PEOPLE AND STEAL
SPOTS RESERVED FOR STUDENT
ATHLETES.
THEY NEVER PLAYED THE SPORT.
THEY EVEN WENT AS FAR AS TO
PHOTO SHOP THE PICTURES OF
THE FACES OF THESE KIDS AND
PUT THEM ON THE BODIES OF
REAL ATHLETES.
THAT'S HOW FAR THIS WENT.
NOW, A 5-MILLION-DOLLAR
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT HAS
BEEN FILED AGAINST 8 OF
THESE UNIVERSITIES ON THE
BASIS THAT CERTAIN STUDENTS
WERE CHEATED OUT OF A SPOT
BECAUSE OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
FAILURE TO PREVENT THE SCAM.
OTHERS ARE CLAIMING WELL
DAMAGES ASSERTING THAT THEIR
STANFORD UNIVERSITY DEGREES
HAVE BEEN IRREPARABLY
DAMAGED AND DEVALUED.
EITHER WAY THIS IS NOT A
GOOD LOOK FOR SOME OF
AMERICA'S QUOTE PRESTIGIOUS
UNIVERSITIES WHICH ALLOWED
MASSIVE CORRUPTION TO FESTER
AT SOME OF THE HIGHEST
LEVELS.
NOW ONE OF THE MOST NOTABLE
PEOPLE CHARGED IN THIS
ONGOING SCANDAL WAS FULL
HOUSE ACTRESS LORI LOUGHLIN
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE PAYING
$500,000?
BRIBES?
FREIGHTLY SECURE SPOTS AT
USC FOR TWO DAUGHTERS.
WHEN LOUGHLIN WAS ARRESTED
SPRING BREAK ON BOARD A
YACHT OWNED BY CROUSO.
THE SYSTEM IN THIS CASE
APPEARS TO BE RIGGED.
WE GIVE EVERY PERSON THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK HARD, THE STUDENTS THAT
STUDY, THEY GET THE A'S.
PLAY BY THE RULES.
EARN THEM, THEN YOU HAVE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE ONLY CARE
ABOUT STATUS AND BRAGGING
RIGHTS AND THOSE SPOTS ARE
TAKEN.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THIS
LATEST TONIGHT.
FIRST, WE HAVE OTHER
BREAKING NEWS OUT OF CHICAGO
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR TOP
STORY, JUSSIE SMOLLETT WAS
BACK IN COURT TODAY.
HE PLED NOT GUILTY TO THOSE
16 FELONY CHARGES, STEMMING
FROM AN ELABORATE HATE CRIME
HOAX SCHEME AND FOUND
GUILTY.
SMOLLETT COULD FACE UP TO 48
YEARS IN PRISON, FORCED TO
PAY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FINES.
THIS COMES AS WE ARE NOW
LEARNING THAT A FORMER TOP
AID TO FORMER FIRST LADY
MICHELLE OBAMA URGED THE
CHICAGO POLICE DEPARTMENT TO
TURN OVER THE CASE TO THE
FBI.
OF COURSE THAT NEVER
HAPPENED AND NOW ALL EYES
ARE DIRECTLY ON SMOLLETT TO
WAS ALLEGEDLY DEFRAUDING THE
CITY OF CHICAGO FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING ALL WHILE
DRAGGING TRUMP SUPPORTERS
THROUGH THE MUD.
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR TOP
STORY, I WANT TO FOCUS ON
HANNITY WATCH.
THE RADICAL 2020 DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES.
YET ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HAS
JUMPED INTO THE RACE.
THIS CASE BEING FORMER
CONGRESSMAN ROBERT FRANCIS
BOZO O'ROURKE.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL HIM.
FLAILING HIS WAVE INTO THE
RACE THIS WEEK LITERALLY
TELLING VANITY FAIR THAT HE
WAS BORN TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
HOW REGAL.
NEEDLESS TO SAY BOZO GOT OFF
TO A HOT START IN IOWA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE HAS
EVER BEEN A GREATER MOMENT
IN OUR LIFETIMES AND FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
THE CHALLENGES HAVE NEVER
BEEN GREATER, MORE SEVERE,
MORE CRITICAL OR MORE
DEFINING FOR THE FUTURE.
>> Sean: ON THE MORE
HUMOROUS SIDE SPEAKER PELOSI
WAS ACTUALLY ASKED TODAY TO
NAME BOZO'S GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS DURING HIS
TIME THERE IN THE HOUSE.
WELL, LET'S SAY IT WAS A
STRUGGLE FOR THE SPEAKER.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT, IN YOUR VIEW WAS
BETO O'ROURKE'S SIGNATURE
ACCOMPLISHMENT AS A MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE?
>> BETO BROUGHT A GREAT DEAL
OF VITALITY TO CONGRESS.
ONE OF THE ISSUES IN HIS --
I HAVEN'T BEEN ASKED THIS
QUESTION BUT I JUST KNOW OF
HIS RECORD HERE, WHEN HE
CAME, HE CAME AS A REAL
CHAMPION FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
HE GOT A GREAT DEAL OF
SUPPORT FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY FROM
HIS DISTRICT.
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
A STRONG MEMBER OF THE ARMED
>> Sean: TOO BAD ALL THAT
VITALITY DIDN'T HELP BOZO
ACHIEVE ANYTHING IN HIS TIME
IN WASHINGTON.
GET READY, IF ZOE BOW
GET READY, BF ZOE BOW
GET READY, BOZZOE BOW
GET READY, BOZOOE BOW
GET READY, BOZO I BOW
GET READY, BOZO ISBOW
GET READY, BOZO IS EW
GET READY, BOZO IS ELECTED
TO HE PLANS TO FLUSH THE
CONSTITUTION DOWN THE TOILET
LIKE SO MANY OTHER 2020
EXTREME RADICAL.
THEY WANT TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COURT JUSTICES
ILLEGALLY RESHAPE THE COURT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE IN
A MINI MONOLOGUE FEATURING
EVERYTHING YOU KNOW -- NEED
TO KNOW ABOUT ROBERT FRANCIS
O'ROURKE THAT THE LEFT WING
DESTROY, HATE TRUMP MEDIA
MOB WILL NEVER TELL YOU
INCLUDING THE TIME HE ALMOST
KILLED SOMEBODY DURING A DUI
HIT AND RUN INCIDENT.
WE WILL SHOW YOU WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TO SAY
ABOUT BOZO'S DECISION TO
RUN.
WITHOUT A DOUBT DEMOCRATS
ARE WILLING TO DO ANYTHING
AND EVERYTHING TO BEAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
EVEN APPARENTLY GIVING YOUNG
KIDS 16 THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I MYSELF HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
FOR LOWERING THE AGE TO 16.
I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO CAPTURE KIDS
WHEN THEY ARE IN HIGH
SCHOOL, WHEN THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN ALL OF THIS,
WHEN THEY ARE LEARNING ABOUT
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE.
>> Sean: MAYBE WE SHOULD
MAKE IT THE LEGAL DRINKING
AGE.
MORE ON THIS THE RADICAL
WAYS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO RESHAPE AMERICA.
VERY DANGEROUS TIMES.
FIRST, LET'S GET TO OUR TOP
STORY, MAJOR HUGE BREAKING
NEWS.
WE BEGIN OUR HANNITY WATCH
TONIGHT ON THE DEEP STATE.
TRUMP, RUSSIA COLLUSION IS,
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AND REMAINS
A MYTH.
AND THE HIGHEST RANKING
MEMBER OF THE FBI KNEW IT.
BREAKING JUST MOMENTS AGO
ACCORDING TO THE HILL'S JOHN
SOLOMON WHO WILL JOIN NEWS A
MINUTE.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AND
CARTER PAGE BOTH MADE
EXCULPATORY STATEMENTS AT
THE VERY BEGINNING, THE VERY
START OF THE FBI'S RUSSIA
PROBE BACK IN 2016.
NOW, ACCORDING TO SOLOMON,
BOTH MEN MADE COMMENTS TO
THE FBI INFORMANT STEPHAN
HALPER MAKING IT CLEAR THEY
WERE NEVER INVOLVED.
THEY HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF ANY
COLLUSION WHATSOEVER.
ZERO.
NOTHING.
THE FBI PRESSED FORWARD
ANYWAY.
POSSIBLY HIDING THAT
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE FROM
THE ALL IMPORTANT FISA COURT
WHERE WE KNOW A FRAUD WAS
COMMITTED.
IN FACT HALPER'S ACCOUNT WAS
NEVER PRESENTED TO THE
COURT.
THAT'S FISA ABUSE.
THAT'S FRAUD BEFORE A FISA
COURT.
THAT'S PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT.
THAT IS AN EFFORT BY A FEW
HIGH RANKING BUREAUCRATS TO
UNDERMINE DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS ALLIES AND, FRANKLY,
HELP STEAL AN ELECTION.
IT'S THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
MODERN HISTORY AND IT IS NOW
THE HOUSE OF CARDS IS
BEGINNING TO FALL.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE OTHER MAJOR
BREAKING NEWS.
LAST WEEK IT WAS BRUCE OHR.
LAST NIGHT IT WAS LISA PAGE.
NOW WE HAVE THE FULL
TRANSCRIPT FROM PETER
STRZOK'S TESTIMONY ON THE
HILL.
AGAIN, COURTESY GEORGIA
CONGRESSMAN COLLINS THANK
YOU THIS IS A HUGE
DEVELOPMENT.
FOR CONTEXT,LET'S REMEMBER
PETER STRZOK VIRULENTLY
ANTI-TRUMP PRO-HILLARY
CLINTON, FBI INVESTIGATOR.
HE IS INVOLVED IN EVERY
SINGLE ROLE HERE, EVERY
INTEGRAL ROLE IN BOTH THE
FBI'S CLINTON INVESTIGATION,
WAIT A MINUTE, MATTER AND
THE SUBSEQUENT PROBE INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND STRZOK HELPED AUTHOR
HILLARY'S EXONERATION
LETTER.
HE WAS AMONG THE AGENTS WHO
LATER INTERVIEWED HILLARY.
HE SAYS HE KNEW HE WAS IN
THE ROOM WHEN THEY TOOK OUT
THE WORDS FROM THE DOJ OH,
GROSS NEGLIGENCE, THE LEGAL
STANDARD OH, RECKLESS
DISREGARD.
AND, REMEMBER, THEY ADDED
THE NEW STATURE OF INTENT,
LISA PAGE TOLD US LAST NIGHT
THIS WENT RIGHT IN TO
LORETTA LYNCH'S OFFICE.
ALL OF IT.
WHAT DID SHE KNOW?
WHEN DID SHE KNOW IT?
WHAT DID SHE TELL OBAMA?
WHAT DID KNOW?
WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
AT THE SAME TIME HE WAS
TEXTING HIS FBI GIRLFRIEND
LISA PAGE THAT HILLARY WOULD
WIN AND SHOULD WIN
100 MILLION TO ZERO.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS WERE SMELLY
WALMART PEOPLE.
THAT TRUMP WAS DEPLORABLE.
EVEN VOWED TO STOP TRUMP AND
SO MUCH MORE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HUNDREDS OF GRAPHIC
ANTI-TRUMP PRO-HILLARY
TEXTS.
AND NOW ACCORDING TO
STRZOK'S FOREIGN TESTIMONY,
WE NOW KNOW THAT OBAMA'S DOJ
LED BY LORETTA LYNCH
CORROBORATING THE TESTIMONY
OF LISA PAGE ENTERED INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE FBI.
ACTUALLY RESTRICTING THE FBI
ACCESS TO HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAILS DURING THEIR
SO-CALLED INVESTIGATION.
INCLUDING EMAILS RELATED TO
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AND
ACCORDING TO STRZOK, I WILL
QUOTE HIM, MY RECOLLECTION
IS THAT ACCESS TO THOSE
EMAILS WERE BASED ON CONSENT
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ATTORNEYS AND THE COUNSELS
FOR CLINTON.
PUTS A LOT OF LIGHT ON THAT
TARMAC MEETING WITH BILL AND
LORETTA LYNCH, DOESN'T IT?
AND STRZOK EVEN COMMENTED
THAT THERE WAS AN EVEN AN
EXTENSIVE FILTER IN PLACE TO
WORK THROUGH THE VARIOUS
CONSENT AGREEMENTS WITH TEAM
CLINTON.
IN OTHER WORDS, LET ME BREAK
IT DOWN.
THE FBI'S INVESTIGATION
WALLS CONTROLLED FROM THE
VERY TOP OF OBAMA'S
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
THE TOP.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS WAS
NEVER A REAL INVESTIGATION.
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN IT
ARE NOW TELLING US.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S NOW
GONE FROM OH, PETER STRZOK,
LISA PAGE, COMEY, McCABE
AND OTHERS TO E OH, LORETTA
LYNCH HERSELF TO THE HEAD OF
THE DOJ.
THE OUTCOME, THEY MADE SURE
WAS NEVER IN DOUBT.
NOW, I WONDER IF ROGER STONE
GOT A CONSENT AGREEMENT WHEN
THE FBI RAIDED HIS HOUSE
PREDAWN RAID WITH, YOU KNOW,
NAVY FROGS AND AMPHIBIOUS
VEHICLES AND 16 VEHICLES AND
27 MEN ARMED, YOU KNOW, IN
THE DARK OF NIGHT, PREDAWN
RAID.
WITH CNN CAMERAS, STRZOK
ALSO CONFIRMED THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN CLINTON'S
EXONERATION LETTER WAS IN
FACT CHANGED AS I SAID FROM
GROSS NEGLIGENCE WHICH IS
THE LEGAL DEFINITION.
IN THE LAW.
THEY CHANGED IT TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS AT THE BEHEST,
AGAIN, OF THE DOJ AND THEIR
ATTORNEYS WHO WERE WORKING
FOR LORETTA LYNCH ON BEHALF,
CLEARLY, OF HILLARY CLINTON.
STRZOK TESTIFIED MY
RECOLLECTION IS ATTORNEYS
BROUGHT IT UP AND THAT
THESE, OF COURSE, WERE DOJ
ATTORNEYS.
THIS IS YET MORE DAMNING
EVIDENCE THAT OBAMA'S DOJ
LITERALLY RIGGED THE
INVESTIGATION FROM THE
BEGINNING SO THAT HILLARY
CLINTON COULD CONTINUE AS A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE WHEN
EVEN THE NUMBER ONE GENERAL
COUNSEL AT THE FBI ARGUED
SHE SHOULD BE CHARGED WITH A
FELONY OF THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
THEY GUARANTEED THAT SHE CAN
CONTINUE WITHOUT FACING ANY
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
OR AS LINDSEY GRAHAM PUT IT
EARLIER TODAY ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
ANYONE ELSE YOU, ME,
EVERYBODY ELSE WE DON'T HAVE
TWO JUSTIFIABLES UNDER THE
LAW IN THIS COUNTRY ANYMORE.
WE WOULD BE IN JAIL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DO YOU INTERVIEW
CLINTON THE WAY SHE WAS
INTERVIEWED ANY AMERICAN OUT
THERE WHO DID WHAT SECRETARY
CLINTON DID.
YOU WOULD BE IN JAIL NOW.
WE LET MUELLER LOOK AT ALL
THINGS TRUMP RELATED TO
COLLUSION AND OTHERWISE,
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED ON THE OTHER
SIDE AND FIND OUT IF THE FBI
AND THE DOJ HAD TWO SYSTEMS.
ONE SUPPORTING THE PERSON
THEY WANTED TO WIN AND ONE
OUT TO GET THE PERSON THEY
WANTED TO LOSE.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN FIRED FOR LYING AND
IT'S NOW TIME TO HAVE IS A
SPECIAL COUNSEL LOOK AT ALL
THINGS 2016 NOT JUST TRUMP
WELL SAID SENATOR GRAHAM
GOOD FOR YOU.
IF AMERICA HAS A EQUAL UNDER
THE LAW SYSTEM A SPECIAL
COUNSEL INTO THE CLINTON'S
CRIMES THAT WERE RIGGED WILL
BE APPOINTED BY THE NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL
IMMEDIATELY.
AND, OF COURSE, WHILE THE
FBI GAVE HILLARY A FREE
PASS, MUELLER SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THAT WAS
TAINTED.
WE NOW KNOW FROM THE GET-GO.
FROM DAY ONE.
FROM THE BEGINNING.
REMEMBER, WHEN STRZOK TEXTED
THAT HIS WORK ON THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION HE
COULDN'T REALLY EXPLAIN ANY
OF THAT AWAY.
THE EXCUSES WERE BEYOND WEAK
AND PATHETIC.
OBVIOUSLY HE HAD INCENTIVE
TO TAKE DOWN TRUMP AT ALL
COSTS.
REMEMBER, HILLARY SHOULD WIN
100 MILLION TO ZERO.
WHEN ROBERT MUELLER
APPOINTED HIM AS A LEAD
INVESTIGATOR AS A SPECIAL
COUNSEL PROBE.
WAS HE EVER ASKED ABOUT HIS
OBVIOUS POLITICAL BIAS?
NO, ACCORDING TO STRZOK'S
TESTIMONY NEVER.
MUELLER DIDN'T CARE, DIDN'T
INQUIRE ABOUT THE KNOWN
POLITICAL BIAS.
AN INVESTIGATION INTO A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY I HAVE
BEEN WARNING EVERYBODY ABOUT
MUELLER.
HE HIRED, OF COURSE, HILLARY
CLINTON'S FORMER CLINTON
FOUNDATION ATTORNEY JEANNE
RAY OR THE FACT THAT ANDREW
WEISSMAN ACTUALLY ATTENDED
HILLARY CLINTON'S ELECTION
NIGHT PARTY IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
BUT BREAKING TONIGHT, IN A
SIGN THAT WE ARE NEARING THE
END OF THE WITCH-HUNT ANDREW
WEISSMAN IS NOW STEPPING
AWAY FROM TEAM MUELLER.
MAYBE TIME TO INVESTIGATE
HIM.